我们是B10研究团队的一员。我们重点关注的重大问题之一就是内存问题。Ben刚才讲的内容确实为我们将要讨论的内容提供了很有用的动机。希望我们能够
更接近于在推理时无损检索相关上下文，这是我们最近研究的主要内容。在内存方面，我们大致看到两种主要
类型。显然，你有相对无损的内存，也就是完整的KV缓存，我们知道这种内存在需求上会线性扩展，但在尝试处理
长期代理型用例时，这成为了一个明显的瓶颈。然后我们又有高度压缩的内存版本，包括微调RAG系统和以自然语言压缩形式写入Markdown风格文件等方法。
压缩。所缺少的是中间内存层，我们坚信这一层对于实现长期代理型用例至关重要。退一步讲，要实现一个可靠的长期代理并让它做有用的事情，关键组件有哪些呢？
我们看到了三个主要组成部分。首先，我们需要有效的压缩内存形式，对我们来说，这看起来像是在KVK空间中进行压缩。第二个部分是
能够在循环中使用内存。核心思想是，如果内存能在循环中反复使用，那么你就能有效地利用内存来完成这些长期任务。而
第三个也是最后一个组成部分是某种机制，将内存投影回权重中。这里的想法是如何把这些经验转化为持久的知识。正如前面提到的，我们坚信
KVK空间的压缩正在成为实现这一目标的有效方法。我们看到现有的方法可以构成一个2x2的矩阵，其中一条轴是选择与综合。
另一条轴是按上下文还是摊销成本。按上下文选择涉及查看完整的KVK空间，并通过某种评分来选择保留或驱逐KVK的哪些部分，以便用于未来的调用。
摊销的意思是预先支付训练成本，然后这个成本被摊销到所有使用该压缩KVK空间的推理时间上下文中。
对于按上下文综合，我们所说的选择与综合的关键区别在于，选择仍然表示原始KVK空间的某个子集。但当我们
说综合时，我们指的是通过学习得到的表示，通常是反向传播到KVK中。一个很好的例子是cartridges论文，它在KVK空间中实现了有效的表示，这是在上下文
时间完成的。我们的方法仍然存在于这个象限中。查理稍后会解释这一点。为了完整性，我们看到了在预训练时间，存在的方法既包括选择也包括综合。比如DeepSeek
正如本已经谈到的，DeepSeek的稀疏注意力是选择适当KVK部分的一个好例子，然后综合再次涉及他们的压缩稀疏注意力和重度压缩注意力。其中有组件
正在综合KVK的部分。现在我将交给查理来介绍我们的方法，我们的方法存在于这个象限中。
这项工作的一大动机是摊销的概念，很多人熟悉稀疏自编码器和稀疏编码。所以如果我们有一些输入，比如
大脑中的神经活动或LM中的密集向量，密度很高，有很多叠加和复杂性，传统的稀疏编码会在每次输入新数据时运行迭代算法，试图找出
潜在变量，最终可能会发现激活的潜在变量，比如如果是一张海边狗的照片，可能激活狗和海洋。然后稀疏自编码器出现了，它们说好的，不用每次输入都运行
这个迭代优化，而是学习一个通用函数f，可以应用到我的x上，应该在所有训练数据上（wx+b）学习输出大致相同的正确
编码。这里的想法是你在训练中摊销推理计算。本质上你是在学习优化器。所以我们就说，我们要把这个想法应用到我们的
压缩KV缓存的问题上。正如穆迪所说，我们有完整的KV缓存，大多数时候通过cartridges和选择方法等，我们运行一个昂贵的推理时间算法来
优化压缩后的KVK应该是什么。我们说，好的，不这样做，我们看看这个黑盒函数的等价物是什么，这样我们可以输入完整的KV缓存，输出压缩后的KV缓存。这就是动机。当你深入
细节时，本质上我们有一个可变大小的KV缓存，因为标记数量可变，我们想要压缩它。所以我们知道需要使用某种形式的注意力或
transformer。假设我有两个查询，所以小写t=2。我将学习查询，它们能够对KVK提出一般性问题。所以这个KVK可能有任意数量的标记。让我们假设在
在这种情况下，我有五个。所以大写T等于5。接下来我要做的是，用静音模型学习我的查询，然后进行交叉注意力，学习对KVK中的每个标记提问。
想象这是一个大的X，我们只是把键和值拼接在一起。然后我们得到一个非常熟悉的公式。所以，我会有一个注意力分数，它就是我查询向量和键向量（kx）的softmax结果。
这里的KX就是我把拼接后的K和V应用我学习的键矩阵得到的结果，V同理。所以我得到了这个维度的球体。我对我的查询有了注意力分数。基本上，我们可以通过矩阵乘法得到输出。
将这些注意力分数与Vx矩阵相乘，然后进行某种输出投影。这就是大家熟悉和喜爱的注意力机制。这实际上是恒等映射，所以在训练开始时，我们只是取现有K和V的混合并输出。
训练时我们做的就是取现有K和V的混合并输出。损失函数本质上是完整KV的模型和压缩KV的模型的KL散度，我们试图让模型在压缩KV下输出相同的内容。
让模型在压缩KV下输出相同的内容。这是一个非常自然的下一个标记损失函数。接下来我会交给哈里讲讲具体的实现细节。
好的。查理刚才谈到了做一次压缩，而我们想要的是实现无限上下文。所以我将谈谈我们遇到的一些问题以及如何解决它们，以实现迭代压缩。
迭代压缩。我们先把这里擦掉。如果我们想迭代使用这种压缩器，最简单的实现方式是：我们有一个KV缓存块，将其压缩成更小的块，然后开始从这个压缩后的KV缓存生成，生成新块后再压缩，如此反复。
现在我们开始从压缩后的KV缓存生成，生成一个新块，然后压缩，再继续。这是最简单的实现，在一定程度上有效，但我们发现，如果只用单次压缩训练，然后尝试迭代使用，效果不会持续很多轮，几轮后就会崩溃。
这在某种程度上有效，但基本上我们发现，如果只用单次压缩训练，然后迭代使用，它无法长时间工作，几轮后就会崩溃。我们找到的稳定性的关键是，在进行KL散度计算时，通常的训练目标是让完整上下文和压缩上下文，然后计算下一个KV缓存的KL散度。
稳定这个方法的关键是，在计算KL散度时，我们不是像通常那样在下一个块上计算，而是再往后一个块上计算。具体来说，我们让后续块参与计算KL散度，比较完整上下文和压缩上下文在这个后续块上的差异。
我们发现在后续块上计算KL散度，而不是在下一个块上，可以更好地稳定迭代。我们比较完整上下文和压缩上下文在这个块上的差异，这样可以进行16次甚至32次压缩迭代，而且仍保持很高的准确率。
我们比较完整上下文和压缩上下文在这个块上的差异，这样可以进行16次甚至32次压缩迭代，而且仍保持很高的准确率。接下来我想谈谈，在迭代过程中，压缩缓存实际上发生了什么，它到底是什么。
我们可以进行16次甚至32次压缩迭代，而且仍保持很高的准确率。我想谈谈，在迭代过程中，压缩缓存实际上发生了什么，它到底是什么。我喜欢这样解释：一个KV缓存，我先画出键，然后画出转置的值。
压缩缓存是什么。我喜欢这样解释：一个KV缓存，我先画出键，然后画出转置的值。所以，当我们考虑一个单一查询时，我们的查询向量与一组键相乘，得到初步注意力分数，然后对这些分数应用softmax。
当我们有一个单一查询时，我们的查询向量与一组键相乘，得到初步注意力分数，然后对这些分数应用softmax，得到非线性注意力概率，再与值相乘，得到最终输出，可能还有输出投影。
对这些注意力分数应用softmax，然后与值相乘，得到最终输出，可能还有输出投影。关键是要注意到，这其实和普通的MLP完全一样，这里的上投影和MLP的上投影一样，这里的下投影和MLP的下投影一样，中间有非线性。
可能还有输出投影。关键在于，这实际上和普通的MLP完全一样，这里的上投影和MLP的上投影一样，这里的下投影和MLP的下投影一样，中间有非线性。所以，这里的压缩缓存实际上是一个MLP，我们从上下文中构造了一个MLP。
中间有非线性。所以实际上，压缩缓存是一个MLP，我们从上下文中构造了一个MLP。这基本上是一种新的生成权重的方式，传统方式是通过梯度下降，但这里我们通过压缩来生成权重。潜在优势是，上下文学习非常样本高效，你只需在上下文中说一次，模型就能记住那个事实，因为它能看到。
传统梯度下降需要很多例子才能学习，而我们有一种机制直接从KV缓存生成权重，允许我们只需在KV缓存中说一次，然后压缩，如果我们能将其与权重结合，或者就当作一组权重保留，那么我们就能实现更样本高效的学习。
你只需在上下文中说一次，模型就能记住，因为它在上下文中能看到。而传统的梯度下降非常样本低效，需要很多例子才能学习。现在我们有了直接从KV缓存生成权重的机制，允许我们只需在KV缓存中说一次然后压缩，如果我们能将其与权重结合，或者就当作权重保留，那么我们就实现了更样本高效的学习。
而传统梯度下降需要很多例子才能学习。现在我们有了直接从KV缓存生成权重的机制，允许我们只需在KV缓存中说一次然后压缩，如果能将其与权重结合，或者就当作一组权重保留，那么我们就实现了更样本高效的学习。
与权重结合或保留为权重，我们就实现了更样本高效的学习。未来我们感兴趣的是同时进行梯度下降和压缩，我们可能想先进行压缩，然后对同一块进行梯度下降，这是我们即将实验的方向。
我们未来想尝试同时进行梯度下降和压缩，可能先进行压缩，然后对同一块进行梯度下降，这是我们计划实验的内容。
我们计划实验的内容。好的。